dans cette
comédie familiale fonds morgan à san
diego maintenant franck a dit moussa sow
virus bénin
[Musique]
de plus la prise de kaboul et la
médiatisation qui a eu lieu il ya eu ce
pont aérien avec encore une fois pas
beaucoup des tractations mais au moins
les trois mille personnes qui ont été
évacuées ont pu être mises à l'abri
directement par contre c'est
complètement hypocrite parce que toutes
les personnes qui sont arrivées ici
pendant la guerre civile juste avant la
prise de kaboul sont en france sont à la
rue sont dispersés harcelé par les
policiers avec les tentes lacéré au
moins une fois par semaine et là rien
n'est fait pour eux
[Musique]